We all know Ghostbusters is the greatest movie of all time, but here's 18 facts about Ghostbusters you probably don't know.
You never studied.
According to legend a trailer was released with a real 1-800 number leading to a recorded message from Bill Murray and Dan Aykroyd.
The number supposedly got a thousand calls per hour, twenty four hours a day for six weeks.
Alternate casting choices included Eddy Murphy as Winston, Michael Keaton as Egon, and John Bellucci as Venkman.
But after Bellucci's death Dan Aykroyd used him as the inspiration for Slimer.
John candy was originally cast in the role of Lewis, and the role of Gozer was originally supposed to be played by Paul Reubens.
In the original script the ghost busters were city workers like firemen. They wore blue jump suits, helmets with visors, and used magic wands.
Most of the movie's best lines are improvised, including:
You're more like a game show host.
When someone asks you if you're a god, you say YES!
Dogs and cats living together, mass hysteria
No adhesive here, just good ole fashion salvia.
The fire house exterior is in New York, while the interior is in LA.
My uncle though he was Saint Jerome.
Saint Jerome is the patron saint of librarians.
These alternate takes revealed different original names for the movie.
Ghost Stoppers
Ghost Blasters
This is what 50 gallons of shaving cream looks like.
Cameo by porn star Ron Jeremey.
Film debut of Larry King.
This is a practical effect, Sigourney Weaver wore a full body cast and was strapped to a post hidden in the curtains.
The term proton pack is never said until halfway through Ghost Busters 2.
The voice of Zuul is director Ivan Reitman.
There is no Dana, only Zuul.
And finally the odds of winning the jackpot on the official ghostbusters slot machine are only slightly higher than the odds of bill Murray appearing in Ghost Busters 3.
So be good, for goodness sake.